almost two years into the pandemic an
easing of covet restrictions in one of
the state's hardest hit
new jersey governor phil murphy
announced he would lift the statewide
mask mandate in schools we're not going
to manage kovit to zero we have to learn
how to live with covid as we move from a
pandemic to the endemic phase of this
virus
in neighboring new york these were the
scenes just a month ago when it was the
epicenter of the omicron variant spread
people waiting hours for a test
today that is no longer the case
here in new york exactly one month ago
ninety thousand people a day were
testing positive for coving today that
number has dropped to less than eight
thousand a day
and the positivity rate a key covet
indicator was a sky-high 21 percent
now that has dropped to less than 5
percent
nationwide coveted cases down over 60
percent hospitalizations down over 40
percent
health experts say the decline of cases
of the highly infectious omicron variant
have little to do with vaccines
a much greater proportion of the
population becomes infected over a
shorter time period and when that
happens
it more quickly can run out of people to
infect the death toll is going in the
opposite direction on average 2
500 people a day in the u.s are dying
from covid much higher than most other
developed countries compared to our
european uh partners or even to canada
and the uk
uh we have extraordinarily low
vaccination rates and even lower rates
of boosters
and that's a a really important
explanation for the increased death
rates in the united states
in a country quickly recovering from the
omicron variant but not the lives it is
still taking a number that now stands at
more than nine hundred thousand
gabriel zondo al jazeera new york